[Music]
to change the game consider the game
change left go the lef koe me Anna and I
have Warren sharp who is dapper he's
ready to go and I'm gonna be honest
we've talked to each other now twice
over the last two days we are both
[ __ ] pumped because I think we both
believe we're about to create some
betting content that people haven't
gotten before and that is gonna
positively impact them on a weekly basis
if you want to get down or if you just
want to watch the games a little bit
differently how you feeling oh I'm
fantastic man week one and the NFL
season the best time of the year so
happy we're ready to go and of course I
totally echo everything you just said
there I think we're going to provide
people with good information stuff that
they're going to be able to learn here
and then take - as they watch the games
yes oh I noticed what they were talking
about exactly and that makes some money
too so I want to start off and I want to
talk about kind of the research you've
been doing this summer how do you
process week one I want to do all of
that but first I want to give you a
present from now on every Friday podcast
is going to start with a different theme
song rod Simba the producer the musical
engineer the music director the king of
the castle I asked him to come up with a
theme song just for you and I told you
this months ago but I never let you hear
it no are you ready to hear it now I am
beautiful people in the back I'd like
you to play Warren sharps new theme song
[Music]
it bags so hard do you like it Warren I
need that as a ringtone this is good I
need man I got chills the regulators and
Ronson but y'all are crazy I have tears
in my eyes because I'm [ __ ] excited
[ __ ] those bags it bags alright ok I've
had enough man I'm excited I got my bets
here I got my season-long bets so I'll
bring these up if I'm ever getting
biased I'm very Pro Ravens I'm very Pro
Eagles on very anti Redskins and
Seahawks and um propane Thurs so if I
get a little bit messed up this year
this is the reason why but leading up
into week one you've now been able to
break down every single game last year
you put out your book the 2019 football
preview if you haven't checked out sharp
football analytics calm or his new site
sharp football analysis calm you're
doing it wrong
but how do you consolidate all that to
week one
what is week one like for you with all
of that information well it's
interesting because I've got a lot
different perspective than some people
who just started tuning in recently
right and and just started you know
maybe bought the book right started
focusing around free agency and then the
draft and then dipped out and we're like
I'm gonna go on summer vacation I'll
come back during the preseason the
difference is this preseason we saw
nobody almost you know we really did not
get the same level of involvement from
those players and so it's definitely a
different vibe heading into week one
we've got fifteen new play callers right
fifteen new play cars
it's insane cuz there's only 32 teams in
the rate and a lot of quarterbacks
played very little in the preseason if
at all and I feel like half the
quarterbacks in the NFL right now are
like three years of experience or less
so we don't even have a large sample
size for them no and so the key is
you've got and that's what I mean I'm
sure we're going to be talking about
sample sizes at some point
but the NFL is tricky it is a small
sample size sport and you can't let that
scare you you have to understand how to
apply small sample sizes but layer on
top without what the context is so when
you do your week one at I we were talked
about this yesterday this podcast over
the year is going to evolve when it gets
to week six seven eight and we start
getting more sample size you're gonna be
able to use your computer models a lot
more week one I imagine you're not even
using it that much at all yeah I mean
some people are using computer models
week one based on last year right I
don't like to do that because I study
these teams and these play callers in
these decision makers and fifteen new
play callers what is their strategy even
going to be this year
what good is using last year's
information and then some people would
look at computer models and for some
reason factor in some preseason data
like but less less reps for the
quarterbacks this preseason coaches more
than ever trying to hide their true
objectives like what what sense would it
make for the Baltimore Ravens to come
out on the field and do anything with
their quarterback with the style of
offense I was reading an article today
that said Lamar Jackson I can't wait to
show everybody our actual offense like
he said that this morning right and and
and that's the point like I just didn't
even want him saying anything I know
season like he was talking about you
know people were asking well how many
paths are you gonna throw and so he
start talking I don't want them talking
about anything because they've got such
a unique offense I just want to see it
unfolded do you play the entire market
week one do you lay off do you play
certain games because I find week one I
always use this example Mike Zimmer has
lost one season opener since coming to
the Vikings it was to Jim Tomsula and
the 49ers and then Tomsula and the
Niners did not win another game the rest
of the year
week one is weird how do you approach
week one I do it like I do any week
except with obviously out the aid of my
computer model but I'm still looking for
value I'm looking at where do I see
these different teams and their starting
lineups and how do I view them
differently than maybe the Vegas market
does then the other public betters do so
looking at spots where I think teams are
over or undervalued and then I'm playing
off of those now in some cases we're
gonna be talking about it on here which
is going to be a lot of fun there are
teams that I like that I might think are
bet against week one because I like this
situation I don't like the number that
they're laying so you know some of the
things that we've been talking about
about you know season-long yeah you got
to play week one as if it's week one you
don't you can't take those preconceived
notion oh yeah like heading into
Thursday night I like the Packers more
than the Bears but I went with the Bears
the game was last night if the Bears
lost I'm an idiot shut up I don't want
to hear about it in the other thing too
is I want everyone to understand this
this is a show where we're gonna talk
about 80s against the Sprint you though
when you bet the NFL you're doing more
first-half totals team totals different
types of teaser parlays how do you bet
the NFL from a expert gamble or better
kind of perspective I look at everything
a bookmaker is offering and then I try
to attack any place that I see value and
oftentimes it's in some of the
derivative markets explain okay so like
not just the totals on the game but dive
into the first half totals dive into the
team totals dive into first half team
totals right some of the layers over
unders is really where you believe
there's some form of an availability in
the NFL to make money well I have a
computer model that successfully beaten
totals for years so I have not wait for
that computer to start can we do some
totals in this show as the show goes on
possibly yeah okay cool but really what
Warren's gonna give us perspective and
there's a lot of line betting sharp
football analysis dot-com is his website
the reason that we're not going to do a
ton of over unders early is because to
be honest people pay a lot of money for
your information so we're gonna have the
conversation where a lot of against the
spread lines because that's what I like
to bet even though I know it's [ __ ]
crazy and at the end of every episode
I'm gonna call my proxy and I'm gonna
enter in my preliminary super contest
picks super contest for people that
don't know it is 5 picks I do not have
my wallet I have Mike
I'm entered as Lefko locks if we win we
are the most accurate the prize money is
about 1.5 million and 33 percent I'll
still do the podcast if we win I promise
let's start off with in a few things
that I'm curious about biggest line
movements you keep track with not even
just when the line started when they
first came out a few months ago but you
believe that there's a something to pay
attention to with preseason line
movements because that's when people
start paying attention huh yeah it's
it's like when do people tune in we'll
win something on TV right so they start
watching some of these preseason
week-one games and then they say well
okay my opinion about this team is a
little bit different so if you look at
like the Philadelphia Eagles for example
they opened lower than this like on
their on the market open but they were
around like eight eight and a half at
the time that week one preseason well
now they're up to ten and so what what
what have we seen so the key is look at
what we've actually seen from the
preseason sure and whether or not that
is a deserving line move you know or
it's not to me it's we didn't see any
Carson wins we saw like I don't think
any for me it's more like the whole
Trent Williams Washington has beat has
they're the reason it went to ten not
eight and a half my question for you is
is as a better do I bet with that
movement do I bet against the movement
or is it a judgement call where I go
what you just said is it warranting of
the movement yeah you have to look at
each situation independently it's good
to note which of the lines have moved
primarily because of what we've seen or
what how our perceptions have changed so
the Oakland Raiders are another
interesting yes they were favored by a
point and a half back at the start of
pre-season week one and then all of a
sudden what are we seeing we're seeing
Hard Knocks they're featured on Hard
Knocks and they look a little
discombobulated can Bob Ewell a Otoniel
Brown situation a lot of like public
questions about the team right and and
when I'm watching the show I'm seeing a
lot of rookies who then or other players
who got cut and aren't on the team yeah
and so it's like I thought this
aquiline daus was good they cut him he's
not there anymore so you know maybe he's
finally back I think we might see a
little bit of tick back towards so
really stressed out at that point a half
and now it's a pick'em so just like from
your perspective you saw through you
when you see that line movement what did
you think I thought that the public was
selling Oakland pretty much I mean
there's no reason for the public to buy
Denver right what we didn't see anything
Joe Flacco didn't look great the only
good thing I saw out of Denver like
that's a major takeaway from like a
national scale is holy crap Emmanuel
Sanders is back from his torn Achilles
he's catching deep passes he actually
looks decent out here so that was a
surprise and then you see you know
Oakland they're winning their preseason
games right they're winning their games
like crushing the Arizona Cardinals for
example but they still look like a team
that doesn't have their act together
what's really interesting is the Broncos
are one of my teams on my I might
substitute them into my super contest
though right on the fringe partially
because there was that article that came
out of Lafleur Kyle Shannon and Sean
McVeigh and they all said the toughest
DC we have to face is Vic Fangio yeah
who do they learn under Jon Gruden who's
Jon Gruden facing Vic Fangio i I think
that Vic is gonna have a really good
feel and look at the Raiders offensive
line Richie incognito is suspended Gabe
Jackson's out for eight weeks and here
comes a Denver front for that I think is
pretty loaded and hey Colt Miller who we
kind of like in Trent Brown who were
wondered might be a one-hit wonder you
guys go up against Bradley chub and Von
Miller in the first game so there
there's something to me that I I'm a big
fan of Denver in week one but I don't
have them on my super contest but when
you poke hole of my five I might move
them in there I do like Denver a lot I
just don't like Flacco at all that's why
yeah it's gonna it's really gonna be
interesting to see how Flacco does they
actually have a receiving back out there
now Theo Riddick right no he's out Oh
Theo is out Theo's out for like the
first he's on the IR for like six weeks
that's right okay so at you bro I've
been keeping track of IR like a
[ __ ] we got to talk about
injuries in a little bit too but they
talk about injuries now how do you
factor in injuries okay we're gonna be
starting something new on our football
analysis that I haven't found anywhere
else and I think it deserves to be
tracked in this manner so I'm pretty
excited I just ordered somebody to start
working on this amazing literally
yesterday what we're going to do is what
I care about and I think we were talking
about this off the air is what starters
are not going to play this game
what starters are in jeopardy of missing
this game so it's not just it's
obviously the the 22 guys that are
projected to start week one but then as
you move through I still want to know
the starters that are out that we're
supposed to be there for the start of
the season that aren't playing in week
four or we fire a cannon and in addition
I want to know okay now a guys coming in
and he's going to be starting because
this guy's out for eight weeks right now
but that guys injured too so I want to
know that also so what we're gonna be
doing is every single Friday coming out
with a single article that's going to
look at each games matchup and which
starters where this game are in jeopardy
of missing based upon the injury report
and then it's gonna get updated again on
Saturday when it's an official final
yeah hide a night injury report is
released so that because normally what
I'm doing for injuries is I'm scouring
Twitter and I'm looking at a lot of the
team reporters and I'm looking at what
those injury reports that they're
tweeting out are so it's not just
limited practice you have no idea the
worst is when a guy doesn't practice on
Wednesday doesn't practice Thursday
returns in a limited fashion on Friday
and Sunday you tend to think he's going
to play and you're not positive yeah and
that's that so doesn't doesn't limited
you kind of have a good idea if it
doesn't doesn't doesn't right those
three days know some of those guys will
still end up playing but they're dear
total total like wild cards in that
situation so that's why this year or
with the super contest I'm gonna call
the proxy but I'm with all of these I'm
gonna put out on Twitter on the left
coast show account and on IG what my
official super contest pics are at 11:00
a.m. on Saturday just because that way
we can factor in the injury reports and
that's when we're due write another line
movement was Minnesota before the
preseason against Atlanta
went from four and a half to three and a
half how did you read that one that one
I don't think is just because people are
liking people saw things in the
preseason Matt Ryan played a lot in the
preseason if you if you look at like the
starting quarterbacks and the snaps they
took it's definitely something that I've
been tracking and factoring in you know
he played a lot and he played despite
getting hit a lot this coach kept him in
the games yes and and which is rare you
know most quarterbacks aren't in that
situation in the preseason especially
like a vet like Matt Ryan I just I think
that's probably more so just a little
bit of some sharper money that was
touching Atlanta some things just to
touch on that game really quick Matt
Ryan all time in Minnesota against Mike
Zimmer is Owen three 19 points and two
games combined when he had cutter it was
like they lost 41 to 28 almost 300 yards
Kirk Cousins has not done great over his
career against that Seattle scheme when
I looked it up when he faced Quinn they
scored nineteen seven versus Seattle in
2018 17 versus Seattle with Washington
2017 not great against the Chargers of
the Niners the other thing is Minnesota
secondary is really hurt right now and I
don't think people are realizing it
there was this movement online right now
where people are going hey Xavier roads
quietly has fallen off and then when you
factor in the fact that he had an injury
late last year which was oh he tore his
hamstring in week 12 last year so he's
still coming off of that Mike Hughes is
probably not going to play on the PU P
and we got McKenzie Alexander's on the
pond the injury report with a hamstring
injury so I'm looking at Sanu Julio
Jones Calvin Ridley and I'm going man
the Falcons if they can keep Matt Ryan
upright if they're gonna have some
opening doubt deep my only concern
on the other side is I look at the
Minnesota offensive line they're right
tackle Brian O'Neill did not play a snap
the entire preseason and he's coming in
they got a rookie and Garrett Bradbury
and his welcome to the NFL moment is hi
I'd like to introduce you to Grady
Jarret well we'll see how this goes
right away but my thing is Atlanta's
front seven is so
small so this game really is it really
feels kind of like close to me I had it
at Minnesota favored by two but I could
see Atlanta won in this game easily
easily I'm so in this game you're
absolutely right I want to see what
Xavier Rhodes does you know how bad the
Arizona Cardinals offense has looked
yeah when they played Minnesota in that
preseason game Kyler Murray was 2 of 225
yards per attempt targeting Xavier
Rhodes against other wide receivers 2 of
8 3.1 yards per attempt look at other
corners against other corners so don't
don't think that that's lost on the
Atlanta Falcons offense yes they need to
fix the red zone issues and then on the
other side of the ball I'm just so happy
we got Dalvin cook back oh that guy is
explosive I'm excited to see how he runs
in his own early down success rate guy
do you believe that while Zimmer is
obsessed with the run and Kevin
Stefanski that they will throw to Dalvin
cook a little bit also or is this gonna
be just let's pound we've invested a lot
on our offensive line and we want to be
the tougher team yeah that's the trick
that's the trick is you got a handicap
the coaches not just what you think the
personnel are going to do and in this
case so many different analytics folks
on the Twitterverse have come out happy
that the Minnesota Vikings were talking
about we're gonna use more play-action
and Kirk Cousins is like I'm reading
articles about play action and Stefanski
is talking about the benefits of that
but the fact is this is a Mike Zimmer
coach team yeah Mike Zimmer fired John
DeFilippo last season primarily because
he was passing the ball a little bit too
much and so the issue is going to be how
much is he going to trust a court
offense coordinator who knows that he
got the job because his predecessor
passed the ball too much and got let go
yes but I think that this offense and
the play calling is probably going to be
on even par with last year if not
slightly improved they're probably gonna
work a little bit of play-action in
there yeah they're probably gonna use a
little bit more dynamic personnel
grouping all their receivers are healthy
right now so it's it's a it's kind of a
dangerous offense from that perspective
but I hope that they don't get they
don't Zimmer it too much
and I think the one thing that we're
gonna watch too is there's a few teams
the Zimmer offense the Schottenheimer
are they gonna throw to see the running
backs more Dallas what's it going to be
with Kellen Moore we are gonna keep
track of these teams because there's a
lot of success rates that you have in
your book that maybe if they do this
they could improve it but if we see
after three weeks they're not changing
anything we're gonna pound them my
feeling about the Minnesota Atlanta game
Minnesota wants to drive like 11 play
drives Atlanta's trying to do three play
bombs to their receivers the one reason
I I nudged Minnesota I if I were to bet
this game and it is Minnesota with three
and a half or whatever I would go the
other way with Atlanta but I'm not that
confident in it but the part of the
reason I went Minnesota it was
home-field advantage it's home field
advantage still a thing anymore Warren
sharp it is a thing but it needs to be
understood and it's the understanding is
different than what it used to be so I
did a little research on this for for
the show
hey appreciate you doing some work we're
putting in the hours to give you guys
some good content here and so one of the
definite things that about home-field
advantage is that it has fallen off
tremendously over the last like decade
couple of decades I'm pulling up the
numbers here hold on by the way guys
four line movements per season for the
weeks going forward what Warren also has
found is that next week's lines came out
what today Thursday Thursday so next
look so week twos lines the local
headlines come out on Thursday so next
week we're gonna look at the look ahead
lines versus how the lines are at this
time next week and sometimes that
movement comes from an overreaction from
the games that weekend and that can be
bet on to something will be kind of
keeping track of as a segment moving
forward yeah absolutely and and that's
that's a good thing to to pay o
attention to because the bookmakers come
out with their number based on their
Power Rankings heading into a game and
much like we thought we knew what these
teams were headed into the preseason
right now the lines have shifted a
little bit because of what we now think
they are the question is are we
overreacting and so that's what we're
going to be
looking at always over everybody over it
especially in we too because there's
only one game to go off of yeah I'm
letting everybody know already week two
I'm gonna try and get most of my money
on teams that are Owen one right there's
like a very huge statistical balance
that like the amount of teams that go oh
and two is like so small
cuz this team this league is a 50%
League man it's a coin flip [ __ ]
League he's smiling because he knows
that I'm on to something
alright let me tell you about the home
dog the home-field advantage so from 91
to 2002 okay so that's 12 years home
dogs beat 52.4% which is the betting
rate that you need to hit to beat - 110
Jews so if you want to make money
gambling on games and you're generally
laying - 110 you have to hit at least
fifty 2.4 percent or better Wow
fifty two point four I've never heard
the decimal point 50 it was actually
fifty to fifty two point three six but
we ran into four so home dogs beat that
nine out of twelve seasons and home dogs
went an average of fifty four point five
percent over that entire 12 year run
okay but since 2003 home dogs are beat
52.4% only two times in the last 17
years so it was nine out of twelve then
it's 2 out of 17 and on average they're
only forty eight point eight percent
just looking at home dogs since 2003
okay so the value of home-field
advantage has definitely decreased and
there's a number of reasons why that's a
factor some relate to like kind of like
economics and the market is strange but
it's like TVs are cheaper more flat
screens are available more cable is
available to people all these things
cost less they're more widely
distributed less people care about going
to the games and partaking in that right
more people want to digest and absorb
multiple games at once yes right so
that's a big factor then you obviously
got the rise of fantasy football which
is distracted people and made people say
like I could go to this game and it's
going to take me an hour to drive - this
is you explaining how home-field
advantage has gone away
how it is been minimized it absolutely
it's it's the same way in multiple
sports this is Gaius this is in Vegas
adjusting you believe that the actual
advantage of being in a home stadium has
gone down a hundred percent so let's
let's talk about this stop talking about
the off field things such as like
fantasy football and fans are more
distracted and there's not as much a
desire to go to these games and spend a
bunch of money on one particular team
let's start talking about travel okay
it's easier for teams to travel now than
it used to be think about like in the
90s when I was giving you some of those
stats when we're home field was real
strong these teams were flying
commercial a lot of times they didn't
have the therapy the massages they
didn't have the in room training like
they weren't able to watch film as
they're flying to play their opponent in
the hotel the night before like there
are so many technological and like
literally physical advantages food is
better we know how to deal with rest
more sleep schedules things of those
types that we didn't know in the 90s
when like the old school dudes like with
Jerry Jones big old teams and Dallas
Cowboys just traveling like we now have
the advantages of there's only so much
since I've never thought about it before
yeah I mean travel is one is definitely
one of the biggest things you also
factor in like player salaries right
like I don't know if it was back in the
90s certainly back in the 70s I don't
know when it probably morphed away from
this but you know you used to have guys
that like they know their schedule they
look at the road games oh man we're
going out in this city we're going out
in that city we're gonna now I think
more guys are viewing it as like
business trips oh yeah business trips
this is the I stand to gain a lot I only
get 16 games I got eight road games like
I can't just take this game off and look
crappy can I had one am i right now
they're also a social media they're
afraid of going out and getting caught
more maybe we can go they're staying in
more bingo
yeah bingo for those I'm air throw those
articles that the tinder was sweeping
the NBA because guys like I can't go out
but I still want to go out man and then
and then the other thing is to now that
we have better technology the officials
are held to better standards and so
before I think officials used to like
others
really cameras like on me there's no
replay so like what's the harm
like I'll the crowds going wild you know
like do these I'll be influenced and now
they're looking at it and they're
thinking you know well I'm gonna be
graded on this like the video is going
to go everywhere the one guy who didn't
call the the off cited the false start
on the touchdown pass in Cleveland I
when the Chargers played the browser
that was saw it yes you know like they
realize that they can't just like screw
the officials are held to higher
standards to so the officiating is a
little bit less biased towards the home
team as well so you factor all that
stuff in and home field is not worth as
much as it was and we could see it based
on the actual wind rates of the home
team and we can also see it on the ATS
rates good because there's not a lot of
away teams in my super contest that's
awesome every time I think of a referee
playing in the crowd I think of that
naked gun umpire scene or he's just like
Steve Reich oh I would love because the
NFL doesn't have that the NBA has had
the obnoxious referees over the years
Joe
humor if you wanna get my cameras name
the bald guy that Joey Crawford
kick out Tim Duncan and [ __ ] like that
take like multiple steps as he's like
MLB had Joe West NFL always had like Ed
Hochuli he'd be like oh he's got muscles
but I would love a ref that's like the
dumbass Raiders coach he'd talked to my
ear so that's 15 yards like I would love
an NFL rough that didn't give a [ __ ] the
best one was the guy got a 15-yard
personal foul for giving him the
business giving him the business
oh so good the other thing that I've
always heard is the public is dumb bet
against the public I see here that there
are three games where the public is on
really heavy
Kansas City 80 per six percent public
Baltimore eighty nine percent public
Philadelphia 87% public warn thank you
for putting in those percentages when
you see that do you is that something
that you think of oh the public's 89
percent I got a better way what do you
think I never it is always concerning if
the public is super heavy on one side
because how often is the public know
more
how often so that is that it's a factor
now I'm not gonna bet a game just based
on any one little thing so the I might
ride with the public you know but more
often than not it's going to be a losing
proposition right to do that like with
frequency during the course of the
season so it's it's another one of those
things that you take into consideration
and you realize that if the public's
really heavy on something the issue is
not that it can't win
the issue is you're not going to get the
same value you're not going to get quite
the same value as you would otherwise
and so when we're betting games we're
trying to look for as much value as
possible yes that's why you're here
because over the years I've been someone
that's bet double-digit favorites out
the ass I have seen a line move and said
I agree with this movement and you're
here because I have a problem and what I
what I need from you is understanding
value because I think what a lot of
people go is they go they can win that
yeah but that's not like they can but
that's not the value there are other
places to find it so you what what
amount of time when it's like eighty
nine percent like that big would you
still make that bet or in the back of
your head go I'm gonna have to look
somewhere else
it's like Baltimore is getting 89
percent public in Miami it makes sense
Miami's in a fire sale right now Laremy
Tunsil Kenny Stills Brian Flores and a
new coach Baltimore I'm picking on to be
the 1 seed in the AFC I'm betting the
over on Baltimore I know that you have
future bets in the can against Miami
because you saw this weeks ago
everything aligns with that but the
public is at 89% how do you deal with
that well in this case situation I look
at it from like a matchups perspective
if we want to talk about this game I
think that this game is going to come
down to the first five minutes if Miami
is going to get they tend to get beat up
a little bit by Baltimore Baltimore
historically has been a physical team
they've beaten up Miami the last few
years like in the same situation we beat
them up physically and I think that
Miami is not the type of team right now
with everything that's going on like I
don't know what's going on inside the
locker room right
I love Brian Flores I've spoken with
Brian Flores I love his attitude I think
he's a really good guy and I think he's
gonna be a really good coach but you
know it's hard I understand that they
felt the obligated to do the Laremy
Tunsil trade because of the value they
were getting back and they should have
done that trade because they did get
tremendous value but it also hurts their
ability to win games this year there's
no what happened to the Lakers all those
trade rumors with all those guys make
you feel like a piece of meat and so if
they get beat up and pushed around early
in that game and Baltimore takes like a
10 or 15 play drive down the field
scores a touchdown and then Miami goes 3
and out like I just feel like that the
lifeblood is gonna get zapped out of
that team early in the game I don't want
to break it down cuz I might be making
that one of my super contests picks I
have not told wor what my picks are no
are you excited yes all right so now
what I want to do for everybody is I
know that we've had crack on before and
one of his main piece of advice was for
betters never chase don't lose it one
chase it for lose it for chase Sunday
Night Football I lost on Sunday I'm
going triple hard on Monday Night
Football
Warren cracks advice is right but that's
not how I work I think like everybody
and I want to know if I don't do good at
1 what do I need to do good at 4 so we
are gonna do four shots one game at 1-1
game at 4-1 game Sunday and then this
week one of them on the night games just
to break down if you guys are kind of
feeling it we're gonna break down
especially Sunday and Monday really your
only opportunities but the big games at
1 in 4 that a lot of people are talking
about not really our value we'll focus
on value super contests so the 1 1
o'clock game that we're gonna focus on
first is Jaguars Chiefs Jaguars new
quarterback and Nick Foles mahomes in
Kansas City the way that I want to break
this down is I'm gonna kind of go
through how I see it and then I want you
to poke holes if you hear anything that
you want to go on right away you just
jump right in ok yes sir first thing
that I thought about with Jaguars Chiefs
Jaguars are missing to practice
this week because of the impending storm
it's supposed to be 98 degrees on Sunday
and I believe that Florida teams have an
advantage in the first three weeks of
the season remember it was 97 degrees
when the Jaguars faced the Pats with
Blake bortles and we were all saying the
Jaguars are going to the Super Bowl
because they looked freakin unreal and
the Patriots were bending over suckin
wind second thing I thought of was Andy
Reed with time last 6 home openers 5 & 1
as the Kansas City Chiefs head coach
home openers on the road he's four and
OH Andy Reid's first win as a Chiefs
coach Warren sharp guess who was against
in Jacksonville the Chiefs won 28 to 2
does that mean anything to you
yeah Andy Reid's great coach III I would
fear going up against Andy Reed because
I love him as a coach I think he's one
of the best ways yes and I'm prepared
always he he always has his team's ready
so when I think of the Kansas City
offense versus the Jacksonville defense
I got a little bit of a pause of all the
games last year for Patrick mahomes his
worst quarterback rating of the season
was against Jacksonville Tyriq ill held
to four for 61 I know the Jaguars
bracketed him but Jalen Ramsey's length
is a little bit of an issue
the thing that's positive for Kansas
City look no more tell van Smith for the
Jacksonville defense they got a rookie
in Quincy Williams they got a backup and
DJ Alexander is on the injury report for
a hamstring injury so I look at the
Kansas City offense and I go I could see
Travis Kelce having a big day flip it
around Jacksonville offense against
Kansas City defense that game last year
Jacksonville moved the ball up and down
on Kansas City the problem was is they
had four turnovers in the red zone our
man Blake bortles had four picks and one
thing I know about Nick Foles he is
gonna be a little bit more protective
excuse me he's gonna be a lot better
with the football than Blake bortles I
do worry a little bit cam Robinson
they're starting left tackle coming off
an ACL and meniscus surgery in the
offseason hello here's Frank Clark I'd
like to introduce you to Frank Clark by
the way they also have a rookie
called JaJuan Taylor I see the Jaguars
trying to pound the rock on the Chiefs
and keep Mahone's off the field
I had the Chiefs at around minus three
the actual line is minus three and a
half
if I were bet in that game which I'm
gonna stay away from I would side toward
Jacksonville at three and a half that's
how I see the game how do you see the
game not different okay good okay so
here let me tell you this when
Jacksonville played Kansas City in
Kansas City last year Kenzie has a good
home field advantage big time
what do you think the line was I think
the line was I remember because I bet
Jacksonville it was like Kansas City
minus six and a half or something like
that Kansas City was only laying three
Wow and what are they laying here in
Jacksonville three and a half three and
a half now it was six and I can tell you
for certainty that that was extremely
sharp position Jacksonville plus 6 plus
5 plus 4 so sharps have been betting
Jacksonville deep embedding Jacksonville
for a while now we are getting towards
the tail end of where there might be
value left in Jacksonville that 1/2
point that half point what look you're
absolutely right Blake bortles
yeah 5 total turnovers in the game ok he
fumbled to bridge that's down he fumbled
to AH they lost the turnover battle by
three but look at the overall entirety
of the game we know how awesome the
Kansas City offense was right yes
Jacksonville had six yards per play
Kansas City only had 6.1 Jacksonville
actually had a 48 percent success rate
in that game Kansas City offense only 42
percent hmm with Blake bortles
Jacksonville was more efficient
offensively now we've got a new play
caller and John Dee Filippo and we've
got Nick Foles I would there's no team
well there's they're in the neighborhood
that's been more hyped this offseason
with ready to take that next leap
Reggie's one out than the Chiefs yeah
right one of the most hype teams and we
know the most important position on the
football team is quarterback we know
that there's very little places to go
worse than Blake bortles was
right so Nick Foles arrow up okay the
issue becomes offensive line is healthy
for Ned as healthy wide receivers are
healthy yes
secondary I mean Josh Allen looks like a
good addition he looks like a graded yes
now the only issue that I have with
Jacksonville is people have this notion
of Nick Foles as the guy who won the
Super Bowl
right but the reality is weeks one and
two of last season go back and lo he was
[ __ ] it was terrible in Tampa Bay now he
didn't have a good wide receivers but
it's not as if Jacksonville has like
studs on their wife you know week one
Philadelphia last season their wide
receivers were banged up God she had
some nobodies over you if you ever bet
in this game if you can get it at three
and a half the only way to go for you is
Jacksonville for me if it gets down to
three
now you're just picking a site you're
flipping a coin and and then you and
that means stay away so when you when
you feel like there's no value you want
to stay away and now we should get into
this little diatribe here for a moment
okay when do you want to back an
underdog okay you want to back an
underdog if you think that there is a
little legitimate chance they will win
that game so one thing that we've done
on this show for years and we would have
the 33% making fun of me all the time is
I'd go the Texans
they're getting six against the Packers
I don't think they're gonna win but I
think they can keep it close you're
telling me never about an underdog
unless you think they can win outright
what you want to be able to do is you
want to have with some confidence the
ability to put a tiny little percentage
of your bet on the money line when
you're backing a dog and you don't want
to think that you're just throwing your
money away okay you want to bet on dogs
that you think have an actual shot at
winning the game now there are going to
be some cases where you know you got a
thirteen and a half point underdog and
yeah you think like the back door is
gonna be wide open in this game and so
like it's just it's you you you cap the
game it you know nine and a half and
you're getting thirteen and a half and
so you think that there's value to go
ahead right that but for the most part
when you're debt back in these dogs that
are like between one and seven points
you don't want to just say well yeah I
think this is a field goal game and they
keep a close you want to say like I
think this is going to be tied late and
they could actually win this game man so
you got to be able to look at the team
and look at the matchups and that's
where I do it a lot differently than
just looking at trends we were
discussing this previously you're gonna
look at the matchups and the injuries
and the coaches and you're gonna pull
all that together and then figure out
like what edges does this dog actually
have and where is the public kind of
overvaluing this favorite in some cases
combine those two if they got it's a
tiny little shot to win then that's a
good dog that you want to back alright
so let's move to four o'clock what was
definitely gonna be the game of the
weekend for four o'clock was going to be
Andrew Luck in the Colts and Philip
Rivers and the LA Chargers and now we're
sitting here and it's like what the
hell's going on with the Chargers I mean
excuse me the Colts so that line
movement what is that at right now seven
well six and a half it was back and
forth I'll do my breakdown first thing
I'm gonna say is there is no home-field
advantage whatsoever with the LA
Chargers wipe that off the books it
doesn't exist in terms of the Chargers
offense and the Colts defense we'll
start off on that Ebor flus is a
defensive coordinator that drops
everybody back he wants you to beat him
with ten eleven play drives I see big
games for Eckler and Hunter Henry this
year but my big storyline bro is
everyone's talking about Andrew Luck
it's the Chargers injuries that I can't
stop looking at Russell o Combe they're
starting left tackle out with blood
clots Indianapolis what did they add a
pass rusher just in Houston other
injuries for the Chargers Derwin James
out for the year they have three
linebackers on their injury report right
now
Denzel Perryman their starting middle
linebacker jeté vez Brown one of their
backup middle linebackers and rookie
drew tranquil Justin Tillery one of
their big defensive linemen that they
had to get because I don't know if you
watched that Patriots Chargers game in
the playoffs last year where Bill
Belichick said I'm just gonna pound you
with Sony Michele a million [ __ ]
times because you're so damn small and
you play seven safeties they tried to
generate Jerry Tillery he's coming off
all season shoulder injury their backup
safety nasir Adderley coming off a
hamstring injury
and a lot of practices I look at this
Chargers team I think they're banged up
and when I did my line I had Indy as a
one point favorite because I believe
luck or without luck okay with luck I
would have liked him at four but I look
at the Chargers and the Colts and I look
at the Colts and I go this is a team
that has an unbelievable offensive line
against what I believe is a very small
defensive line I interior boasts in
Ingram are phenomenal
but I think the Colts can push them back
a lot I think now they've had a few
weeks to go nobody gives us any [ __ ]
respect I think they have the better
coach I think that Jacoby brusett is a
solid quarterback and I know you have
more statistics on this and I think that
the Chargers the way they beat the Colts
is by sticking with the small gains but
this is Philip [ __ ] Rivers and I like
the Colts matching up secondary with
these wide receivers I really do
I like the Colts to win this one out
right it's gonna be one of my super
contests big zoom all right so do you
see it like that do you see opposite am
I going too far no I don't think you're
going too far it's a good opportunity to
bet the dog if you think they can win
outright so you're on the right page
there I took your advice you took my
advice I think it's going to be
successful for you whoo let's go let's
let's break down first of all where
we've come in this last couple of weeks
yes the Andrew Luck situation right the
Colts were one of the Superbowl
favorites and then they lost Andrew Luck
who is one of the most valuable
quarterbacks in the NFL right in terms
of the line they went from the least
odds to win the division I think they
went middle of the pack to go to the
Super Bowl everybody reacted really hard
now if you look at this team when they
were sort of betting favourites to win
the division to what you know make it
today AFC championship game I mean they
were number three I think below the
Colts and the Patriots I'm sorry but
below the Chiefs and the Patriots what
were we talking about we were talking
about a team that we thought I love
their coach look how deep this roster is
look at the talent that Chris Ballard
has assembled here all the things that
like stand out
you about this roster yes have not
changed except for Andrew Luck that's it
so let's take a look at now what was
Jacoby burr set well I've seen people
write articles and talk about Jacoby
reset as a four and twelve quarterback
because that's what he was when he
played for quarterback in 2017 but her
luck missed the whole year when he
missed the whole year well people don't
understand his context and I think for
the 33 percent we're gonna be talking
about this a lot this season Wade says
we have a small sample size sport we
have to understand context Jacoby
Brissette comes to Indianapolis on
September 2nd I believe on Labor Day
weekend of 2017 she was a four days ago
exactly four days ago in this year
played none of the preseason games got
zero practice reps during training camp
with the team because they thought
Andrew Luck was going to play they
legitimately thought that Andrew Luck
might play okay week one Jacoby
Brissette doesn't even know the PlayBook
yet he doesn't even he's not the
quarterback week one because he just got
there so they have a different
quarterback week when he goes to the
Rams and gets pasted by Sean McVeigh in
his first guy who was that quarterback
it was some little white guy I remember
that Keep Calm keep it so he gets
absolutely destroyed and they're like we
got to go with Jacoby week two because
this guy doesn't stand a chance
okay so Jacoby comes in week two and
what do we know that happened
they they they only want four games out
of their next eleven however what people
don't realize is that that Indianapolis
Scott tolsey Cozine yeah keep going
what people don't realize that Jacoby
percent led team in the 15 games he
started led entering the fourth quarter
in nine of the 15 games that is like a
mind-blowing number because the number
of I think there's been no other team in
the last 20 years to hold leads in at
least nine games entering the fourth
quarter and only win four that's what
that cold Steam did that's how bad they
were so you say well why did they blow
so many leads totally predictable play
calling they were using Frank Gore to
run the ball they should have been using
Marla Mack in the fourth quarter when
they ran the ball they had
totally giveaway formations when they
had three wide receivers in that fourth
quarter out on the field 100 percent
pass less than three he was running the
ball 100% percent the only team in the
NFL like I go back and look at this crap
so I actually so when when he would go
out there with three wide receivers the
defense could just yell each other
they're passing the ball with a hundred
percent certainty and in analytics
whatever is 100 percent certain right
now yeah the fact of the matter is like
week two week three week four you don't
have a lot of data to go on so you're
not necessarily gonna be looking at that
at that point in time however like later
in the season it's it's far too
predictable now I don't know how many
other teams are looking at that I
certainly look at that when I'm
consulting with teams I'm giving them
those types of information but I don't
know if their opponents were but I could
tell you like people internally with the
Colts who were not calling the place
we're pretty pissed off because they
could see all these leads that they were
blowing but the public just sit thinks
well this team sucks so that's why
they're blowing the leaves and you're
liking the Colts right now so I still
think that the Colts are right now
undervalued imagine being in that locker
room imagine being in the Indianapolis
Colts locker room or being Frank Reich
coaching this team and you are projected
to win this division you are projected
to be one of the best teams to go to the
Super Bowl okay and then Andrew Luck
retires boom bombshell right and then
every single person out there Konya says
oh this team is done I can't believe
what happened Andrew Luck is gone they
have the massive disrespect card it's
bigger than anybody else's disrespect
card this entire season it trumps
everything Frank Reich is the same guy
that came back bills Oilers all those
years ago and I want to say this the
Colts have had a few weeks now to put
their questionable return guy to bed
it's asleep you know what the chargers
are thinking about Sunday
I wonder how Melvin will be doing right
now and guess what they're thinking
about man my team doesn't want to pay
this guy that we know would make him
better
so the Colts have put their question to
rest and the Chargers are sitting in it
and Analia Coates put their question to
rest they paid you Kobe perset for an
extra year yeah vote of confidence right
is our guy rondalee lawyer so the
quarterback root okay okay then think
about how Melvin Gordon what that
situation is going to be like the first
few drives of that game if the run game
doesn't go too well
if Eckler does one of his famous fumbles
it could be issue all right let's go to
Sunday night Steelers Patriots this is a
game that has a lot of attention I'm
gonna go quicker than I have before Tom
Brady
he's record at Foxborough against the
Steelers what do you think it is Warren
sharp out of five games four and one or
five in a five and oh he's played them
in 1713 fifteen seven and two two times
he faced them and see in season openers
2015 and 2002 his touchdown interception
ratio and those games weren't sharp what
do you think it is impeccable 18
touchdowns no interceptions and he's
averaging 360 yards per game the average
margin of victory is 17.4 points per
game Big Ben one in four at Foxborough
his one win Brady wasn't there in his
last three he's six touchdowns four
interceptions my big question though for
the Patriots their interior offensive
line they lose David Andrews to blood
clots I shouldn't have this question
because it's Donte scar Nekia but I will
say the interior defensive line for the
Steelers is probably their strong suit
Stefon to a cam Hayward and we know that
Brady was pressure in his face that's
probably the one time you can get them I
have a lot of unanswered questions about
Pittsburgh's injuries right now because
Tomlin is not giving out any information
Sean Davis Joe Haden bud Dupree Anthony
chicle Oh mark Baron I have no idea
where they are
this is something I have to pay
attention to on Saturday also I think
New England's can have a lot of problems
with Steelers team speed defense I think
that I look at the the Patriots they're
one tight end is banged up and I don't
think any of their wide receivers maybe
Josh Gordon is gonna really get away
from any of these guys
I think the Steelers defense is great
however I think the Patriots secondary
is the best in the NFL and I think they
may match up with the Steelers offense
better than any team in the NFL you put
JC Jackson on juju you can corral Connor
with all those
I'm backers that they got you got Devin
McCourty put him on anybody
put him on Vance McDonald we're feeling
good and I need to be proven that James
Washington and Donte Moncrief can be the
guy I think that the Patriots defense
matches up amazing I have the Patriots I
had about minus three and then the line
is five and a half I think the Steelers
can keep it close I think they can win
but I don't really want to bet this game
I don't like betting against the
Patriots at home but I also don't think
the smart odds are on the Patriots right
now so personally I'm avoiding this game
what do you think yeah um if I had to do
anything you know there's a way that I
would look it would probably be towards
a dog but you don't have to do anything
you look at Steelers plus five and a
half if you worried about it
yeah and I'm probably not on that side
because of a lot of the reasons that you
said I think the Steelers are gonna have
a little bit of success running the
football I'm big on James Connor this
year I'm curious to see how the
Pittsburgh Steelers are going to be
passing the ball what their frequency is
because they've led the league in like
pass attempts in terms of pass frequency
but now they don't have the a be out
there so are they going to you know some
of those passes that usually go short
are they gonna be less efficient are
they gonna try to run the ball a little
bit more I've got questions there and I
think the Patriots look coaching
mismatch to the high heavens here like I
do not have a lot of confidence in my
Collins ability to game playing against
this this offense right but this offense
like you said is kind of banged up and
there's a lot of question marks on that
side of the ball and I don't like the
injury to the starting center I think
they're gonna be fine
you know wins going to be great but
Patriots historically have started slow
like after week four I think we have
statistic that at home they're
unbeatable but before week four they're
very beatable at home but I think that
David interesting so you're you're
looking at it going
the value is with the Steelers and the
number but the problem is is that you
have so much faced in Belichick and so
little faith in Tomlin that it just
makes it a coin flip and you don't want
to be involved yeah as of right now
unless the injury information brakes a
little bit differently I haven't done
anything yet on this game and because I
- your appointment I could see the
Steelers pushing around that deal
of the Patriots lissa d-line that lost
Malcolm Brown and you look at the rest
of the D line sure Michael Bennett's
great but he's smaller they lost Eric
rivers it's Adam Butler Lauren sky Danny
Shelton that can be pushed around by a
phenomenal Steelers offensive line it's
gonna be a great game to watch I just
don't think a good game to bed I hear
you you agree with me I agree all right
so what do you think my analysis thus
far on point yeah really good I've got
the injury information you got stats you
backing it all you got it you got to
look at everything from like a
well-rounded perspective yes and you're
bringing it okay then the Monday Night
Football game I appreciate you saying
that any of the confidence boost Saints
Texans we do not have any information
right now on injuries so take that with
a grain of salt those injuries even the
preliminary injury reports aren't out
yet first thing I'm going to say is
which of these which of these runs mean
more to you on the road under Bill
O'Brien in September the Texans are one
in five the Saints straight up in the
first two weeks of the last five seasons
are one and nine their only win in the
first two weeks of the last five seasons
was against the Browns last year I think
that's kind of crazy what do you think
about those runs it's it just speaks a
little bit towards the coaching and the
preparation you know I think coaching is
is one of the motion or the government
shine knows one one game in the first
two weeks the last five years that
doesn't make sense to me it does not
there's obviously a little bit of
variance sprinkled in there but if you
asked me how many he would have 1 out of
10 I would have said more than once
no so you see that as a trend that's
interesting but there's too much context
that we're not paying attention to
probably that and it sounds like you got
like both coaches are in a similar spot
where they're not as yes so I look at
the Texans defense right now I don't
think they're linebackers are that great
I don't think their secondary is good at
all they probably lost one of their best
cover guys in Kareem Jackson they lost
tire in Matthew I see this as a one with
a lot of shootout possibilities I think
the guy that no one's talking about
that's phenomenal as DJ reader I had the
line at Saints minus seven and then it
was Saints minus seven is there
any other information about this game
that that sticks out to you or do you
think I'm missing no well there's a lot
of other information we're not going to
be able to dive deep enough into it
right now but I think that this game is
going to be exciting to watch I think
I'm gonna see if my questions are
answered about this Houston Texans
defense because they played the most
laughable schedule of opposing
quarterbacks last season it was
definitely something I noted in my book
yeah how all these backups I mean you
you're your brother-in-law could have
been I mean like they didn't play
anybody of caliber except for like game
against Brady and you know now they have
to go up against Drew Brees and Sean
Payton right a team that knows how to
game plan against that defense
potentially so I want to see how
Houston's defense ends up looking here
man
but right now seven feels like a good
number it feels like an accurate number
maybe okay maybe is there a side you're
leaning to right now or is there an
over/under that you're feel like the
over I I've said I want to hit every
Texans over for like the first few weeks
before it gets calibrated I just think
this is a team that has destroyed its
defense to build up its offense my
conspiracy theory is Bill O'Brien's
gonna go oh this is the year I'm kind of
on the hot seat but look at my offense
we're top six stills and Hopkins and and
Kiki catty and and will fuller and now I
have my left tackle like it's all
offense right now at the Texans it is
but what I want to see is Bill O'Brien
is such a run heavy coach they run the
ball a ton but they don't have like that
Bell Cal that they used to pass catching
runs Oh Duke is more of like that
traditional third down back that you
would put in there as like the scat back
to catch those passes he can run some
between the tackles but that's not his
strength especially on early down sis's
Hurley so I'm intrigued to see does Bill
O'Brien change his stripes and coach
optimally to his roster or does he stick
with the philosophy that you and I both
know is less efficient towards winning
games that'll be the thing interesting
to see thing to see when the Texans have
the football all right so now what we're
gonna do is I'm going to make my five
Super contest picks you have not seen
these you don't know where I'm going
go I'm gonna get your initial reaction
and then I'm gonna explain and then I
want you to kind of be my therapist
because Warren I come to you a better
that has had some success I'm a 50%
better so that's probably a lot of
failure but I'm coming to you to set me
straight first one that we've already
talked about I'm gonna be going Colts
plus six and a half at the Chargers what
do we think what is your what is your
gut would you steer me in a different
direction or would you support me I
would support you you would okay do you
want to expand on that anymore I've
already given my we we hit that game
pretty good so I think I think I think
we're good okay
the second game that I am gonna go with
is going to be are you looking at your
screen
mmm-hmm Carolina plus two and a half a
home dog your initial feeling about that
I don't mind it actually okay I don't
mind it
okay here's my reasoning okay Carolina's
won their last five openers and I get a
little scared because the rams under
McVeigh they've won their two season
openers by a combined 57 points so both
good teams in week one
game is healthy I'm not worried about
that I look at the Carolina offense with
Cam and I see a Rams defense that I find
to have taken a step back this year
no Indaba can sue I fight they just lost
their starting inside linebacker Micah
Kiser the the Rams have added Clay
Matthews who I believe is over the hill
and they're starting a middle linebacker
is now going to be replaced by a special
teamer in Bryce Hager and I'm going oh
so you have slower and older linebackers
and you're facing Christian McCaffrey
okay that's the first thing that I
thought of I also think Carolina's
offensive line is healthy and I think
they're very good and I think that
they're gonna have they're gonna no one
stops here and Donald to be able to
handle it but the real advantage I find
is the Rams offense against the Carolina
defense
I think Carolina's secretly has the best
front four in the NFL maybe front seven
kiwanis or Gerald McCoy Don Terry
against a Rams offensive line and
interior offensive line that's losing
their best guard Roger Saffold and their
Center Jonathan Sullivan and going to
Joseph Noteboom and Brian Allen I'm
seeing a change in the interior of the
offensive line of the Rams and the best
position for the Carolina defense Jared
Goff also on the road
touchdown interception ratio 11 to 10
also of any quarterback in the NFL
nobody was impacted by pressure more
than Jared Goff with a clean pocket his
passer rating was four when he's under
pressure his passer rating was 28 and I
just told you that I think the Carolina
defense is gonna come right up into the
face I saw this originally I thought
those Panthers at home I thought it was
Panthers minus three and then I go and
look at the line it's Rams minus two and
a half I liked Carolina a lot that's my
argument well like if you look at the
season win totals and everything where
Carolina is seven and a half and where
the Rams are it does make sense the
Carolina would be favored in this spot
by the line makers because of the power
rankings you mean the Rams Raiders would
make sense that the Rams would be
favored yes one of the interesting
things that I think about when I'm
looking at this game is I remember Sean
McVeigh after that Super Bowl right and
he was torn up from that game and I
remember his quote afterwards where he
was talking about how much it stuck with
him how difficult it was to get over
that game how much he kept thinking
about it and how that much that lingered
into his offseason
it still affects him today I mean some
of the coaches that went lose his Super
Bowl never going to fully get over it
right but I felt like you know he saw it
was a close game for most of it he saw
these opportunities and then he probably
looked back as like I didn't take
advantage of X or Y and it bothered him
they get Cooper cut back and they're a
lot better with him but this offense
hasn't done anything in the preseason
and you could say well there's such a
Wailord machine they're just going to
come back and be just fine
maybe they won't though maybe maybe it's
going to take a little bit of an
adjustment will Sean McVeigh do things a
little bit
you know this upcoming season will he
still use the same personnel groupings
really use a little bit more 12 those
are things that are to be determined you
you know that I'm a little bit higher on
the Panthers than those people are yeah
and so I look at them and I was really
impressed by what I saw from my hand I
got a lot of the South man and so I
think there is a decent shot there
they're gonna have to come out and hope
that LA playing out on the East Coast oh
that's right and it's a West Coast team
at one o'clock on the East Coast slows
down does that still matter is that
something that you still look at I've
heard that fluctuate over years it does
it matters a little bit but it's not as
what it once was right with all the time
to travel yeah so it's definitely not
working against you let's just put it
that way if it's helping it's helping
you right so is that another thumbs up
from you there yes a dude um I'm so
locked in right now bro okay this one I
need your advice my third one is one
that this is one that I would typically
have bet in the past and my gut is
telling me that I'm wrong and my brain
is telling me that I'm right okay
interesting Baltimore - six and a half
in Miami we just talked about how
they're getting 89 percent of public
money I don't [ __ ] care Warren am I
crazy or am i okay what's your gut
feeling right away before I get into it
it's the first five minutes like I said
earlier okay first five minutes you
don't have Laremy Tunsil they're the
offensive line was already mess what is
okay here's my initial take on this game
what is the main thing that everybody is
saying that the Baltimore Ravens like
what is their biggest problem the
biggest problem it's not the secondary
downfield passing well offensively oh
yeah offensive filling up a pass rush
yes defensively it's it's that question
about the front 7/8 lost za'darius smith
because it was gonna replace because
when I look at their offense it's gonna
be better than it was last year is look
Lamar Jackson is going to pass the ball
better down the field then he did last
year I mean if we want to talk in
generalities but if we want to talk
about this team versus last year what is
the number one thing people are saying
again against them it is they lost guys
on the defense that are leader
that can get after the quarterback what
is the one opponent in the league
possibly more than any where it does not
matter necessarily if you've lost some
of those guys you are still gonna have
an edge so you are still going to be
able to compensate and that's this game
begins the Miami Dolphins the Dolphins
offensive linemen they are starting to
rookie guards their left tackle is
Julian Davenport who we were making fun
of on the Texans and the right tackle is
Jesse Davis sign me the [ __ ] up for the
Baltimore Ravens Miami does have an
insane for home-field advantage and it's
something that no one talks about and
it's could be 94 degrees on Sunday and
they've won three in a row at home in
September over teams that they were
probably not as good at but you know
where the quarterback of the Baltimore
Ravens is from [ __ ] Miami so Lamar
Jackson ain't gonna be tired at all
I don't were you gonna go with this well
I was gonna ask you know when I've seen
hurricanes move through the area
generally after they leave less humidity
and I don't know if that's gonna move
through too quickly or not dude you're a
meteorologist - you've got we got a
factory and all the like the wind speed
the direction of which it's blowing
across the field
how much precipitant things that'll come
into play as we talk about these games
but heat with less humidity doesn't feel
the same as heat and huge humidity so we
got to see what it's going to be like by
Sunday so I have no concern about the
Ravens defense at all like Ryan
Fitzpatrick under duress making
questionable decisions with Baltimore
secondary who might be second best in
the NFL really good other thing Ravens
offense three tight ends power football
offensive line
you know the interior linebackers
because they traded Kiko Alonso the
Dolphins one of them played in the CFL
and the other weighs less than 230
pounds Lamar Jackson just as he'll Mark
Ingram Gus Edwards Nick Boyle Mark
Andrews it's just a flurry of
combinations and big people and heavy
sets and the Miami is gonna switch to a
three-four and their first game is going
to be against Baltimore
like I hope you know your assignments
everything about this game makes me
think the Ravens are gonna win 30 to 6
it won't be as bad as the Buffalo game
last year with Nathan Peterman the only
thing that scares me is that it's in
Miami
Ryan Fitzpatrick has a shamrock up his
ass and the temperature might get hot
but I'm [ __ ] all over I thought it was
Baltimore - thirteen and a half and so
when I saw it was six and a half I was
like okay you know Lamar is not gonna
get that respect but what I will say is
this one of the interesting things is we
saw in the preseason a quarterback
battle go down in Miami that Rick and
Rosen so let's think how does this apply
to what we're doing for week one they
were running their offense they were
trying to see what these quarterbacks
could do the snaps they're there well he
got half the snaps but in addition they
were showing what they were trying to do
during the season Baltimore was hiding
everything so which defense has an
advantage I'm pounding the [ __ ] out of
this
I think I'm three for three right now
okay my fourth pick four I know I won't
be laying Baltimore but I'm not
disagreeing with it so you wouldn't do
it I'm not I I personally have not done
it I see a lot of opportunities on this
card I really like this week one card
more than most Wow but but what I'm
saying is that I would not be back in
Miami here but I am not probably going
to be on Baltimore I'm not saying you're
wrong I'm just saying that okay I don't
disagree
I'm just not on it my fourth team are
you ready
Buffalo plus three Warren came into the
studio and he said left ko I know you're
high on the Jets I don't know about this
week let me show you you're obviously on
my side with this one yes sir the reason
I love this is because I had this one as
a pick'em and I look at this game and I
think that there's the first thing I
focused on was we have statistics about
how Adam GaSe has done against Buffalo
and I looked it up and it ain't pretty
gates and his games against McDermott
averaged 17 and a half points per game
everything about gates is underneath
everything about McDermott is keep you
in front of me with the zone so this is
Sam Darnell gonna have to pick apart a
super-active zone Buffalo returns for
their five starters in their back end
their safeties are phenomenal their
corners are really talented their
linebackers are athletic they all and
they've all played together Sam darn old
I think is gonna be very confident this
is a Bills game word Arnold this is the
game
where'd Arnold led the comeback win
against Buffalo that started him having
a 99 quarterback rating and 6 to 1
touchdown to interception ratio for the
last four games of the year
so Darnell will be confident but I think
it's gonna be a tough matchup and I
don't know if he's gonna have the
opportunities to beat him deep I'm very
worried about the Jets offensive line
health Bryan winters limited practice
with his shoulder Ryan Khalil they're
starting Center he came out of
retirement on August 1st and it's not
like Ryan Khalil was great last year so
I'm looking at Sam Darnell with a guy
that just came out of retirement and
he's going up against and Oliver and and
star Lou - lele and all those guys that
you know Buffalo's got the horses
Buffalo's offensive line against the
Jets d I think it's gonna be a tough
matchup but I think Buffalo's offensive
line is deep they got a lot of dogs they
got a lot of tie in a sec ease you know
what I mean like dudes that are not
gonna get beat often the one big
mismatch because I think this is gonna
be I really think this is a pick'em the
one place where I think he can change is
the secondary for the Jets is banged up
big-time
Rashard Robinson is suspended Tremayne
Johnson has a hamstring injury they just
traded with Indianapolis to get Nate
Hairston like week ago so he's gonna be
one of their guys in the rotation Allen
Josh Allen is the league leader in
throwing deep passes by percentage the
defensive coordinator for the Jets is
Greg Williams he is aggressive as hell
and he will leave dudes on an island I
don't even play DFS like that but one
dude that I would throw a flyer on is
John Brown let's dial it up deep and
seaweed he can do and if Buffalo gets
that deep shot I think it turns I think
it starts Sam door
I'm thinking a lot and it puts more
pressure on the Jets to go we got to try
that thing against Robbie Anderson and I
don't know if that's necessarily their
offense right away I I see the bills
winning this game by one so I'll take
the three right there and I really like
the bills in this situation yes so this
is one where this line to me is not
necessarily wrong right the Jets are at
home it's a divisional game they're
favored by three that's what it's
supposed to be however due matchups
dictate that the bills might have a shot
here and when you talk about the
matchups I think you're absolutely
correct yes
so dude I'm on fire right now you are
I'm really liking your card so far but
let's talk about where I think the
biggest concern for me back in the bills
is absolutely their offensive line
because while they added pieces and
Mitch Morse is back from his concussion
and he's they're starting Center
definitely an upgrade the issue becomes
how much of they played together and how
well are they going to do against
picking up all these blitzes right
because communication along the
offensive line and knowing where to be
and who to pass guys often sprains
Greg's brains a ton of blitzes that's
really my biggest concern if Josh Allen
can survive those blitzes and get the
ball out of his hands the one thing that
Buffalo did that's unique and I talked
about it in the book but not many other
people were talking about is they got
rid of the tall lanky big wide receivers
and brought in Cole Beasley and John
Brown the short quick speedster guys who
can quickly get open as opposed to I've
got a bigger reach than you and I'm
better than these men yeah so I'm gonna
just you could throw the ball to me and
I'll grab it because you're DB's down
here what they're gonna end up doing is
get open real quick off the line and
that's that intermediate pass has
improved from Josh Hollan it was his
biggest weakness is throwing with
accuracy on the shorter times I'll tell
you right now my gut tells me that I'm
worried about his accuracy okay you know
III legitimately am but here's another
thing that you didn't mention that I
think is of note I you mentioned the
offensive line of the Jets and I don't
like that matchup against Sean McDermott
yeah the interesting thing is how well
will Le'Veon Bell run behind that line
because he's so used to
in Pittsburgh the horses up front the
way that he's going to run with patience
timing and then explode through a hole
that they slowly open up if none of
those holes slowly open up because this
offensive line is different how long
will it take for Le'Veon Bell and I
think he's a stud right but we didn't
see him last year how long will it take
for him to get to where he needs to be I
don't understand I haven't seen it yet
and so I want to see it to really feel
how he's gonna run behind this offensive
line
my prediction that's not related to
anything the star of this game that
people will be talking about on Monday
is gonna be Tremayne Edmonds of the
bills I think what you just said about
levy on kind of dancing a little bit and
you have in my mind one of the best
athletic freaks really in the NFL at
middle linebacker Jimmy Edmonds that's
just gonna be sitting there with them I
think that Tremayne Edmonds is gonna
leave this game with like 12 to 15
tackles I think your apps I think I want
levy ah to be successful
but early on he's gonna have to get
adjusted to his Center getting blown
back and his right guard not getting on
the pole because no offensive line did a
better frickin pull than the Pittsburgh
Steelers and anywhere and he could
follow that perfectly and I look at I
mean David to Castro number one the NFL
in pulling guards I don't know if I can
say the same thing about the Jets right
now with Bryan winters no and banged up
no and we mentioned and you mentioned
this like here are some of the numbers
Sean McDermott's defense held Adam GaSe
his offense over the last two years for
meetings 16 16 17 and 21 now I do think
that Sam darn I'm really big on darn
'old this year I think he's going to
throw over 22 and a half touchdowns
passing which is what his number is set
I think he's going to do well this year
but you know this is this opportunity
for us to look in the opposite direction
potentially okay my last one I am
thinking Detroit - three in Arizona this
feels like an old Adam bet as well
here's my reasoning what's your gut
reaiize that is that the number in the
contest right now I believe it is
Detroit favored by three in Arizona are
you seeing it differently somewhere else
I mean it's pretty much two and a half
across the
or but at Westgate it is three okay so
Sam I'm still taking it here's my
reasoning
Arizona's secondary right now is a mess
Patrick Peterson is suspended Robert
Alford is on IR they're starting
tramaine Brock and rookie Byron Murphy I
look at the the Stafford and I would be
buying Kenney gala day big time I also
looked up Patricia
versus mobile quarterbacks last year how
did he do against them in the run
because I'm expecting Kyler Murray when
thing breaks down to run Russell Wilson
to carries 15 yards Mitchell sure Brisky
three carries 18 yards Cam Newton two
carries two yards Josh Allen 9 carries
16 yards the one thing Patricia can do
is scheme up on defense I don't like
what he asked his offense to do and be
so run reliant but I think Detroit has
under the radar one of the best
offensive lines in the league of Mike
Daniels is healthy with a jean Robinson
and snacks Harrison and what how they're
gonna clog up the lanes
I think slay and that secondary matchup
well I know they're banged up a little
bit in the linebackers but I don't know
what Kliff Kingsbury is gonna do but I
know that Patricia is gonna be ready for
it I'm taking Detroit - three I don't
love it okay yeah I don't know enough
about Carroll about about the Cardinals
that's the issue right I like to look
and I get a better understanding here I
want to do some projections right
because I feel like I know the league
better than a lot of other people I'm
kind of betting against imaginary stuff
right now we don't know what this
offense is supposed to be they're
supposedly hiding a bunch of stuff but
were they hiding the splits of their
offensive line in the preseason where
guys were cutting right through them
splits the clapping all of that now I
know Arizona has a low-key huge
home-field advantage they didn't know
what is that they're just extremely
solid at home I mean they're they're
their win rate is better than what you
might expect games tend to be a little
bit lower scoring
so four four teams less accustomed to
playing there now guess what
Detroit played there last year and the
island seventeen to three thousand seven
points per darris lay pick six but they
did go there and they did win right and
that was obviously against a much worse
Cardinals team but the question is this
game is going to come down to my opinion
the way that bat Patricia plays is
totally opposite what keep cliff Kings
here e plays I still think it's gonna
come down to the trenches I think it's
gonna come down to and I think Detroit
is so much bigger on both sides of the
ball than Arizona it's it's laughable
this is this is a trench game this is a
trench game and whether or not that
Detroit offensive line can push back
because I know Arizona has got some
problems on the back half yes but they
want to start Patricia wants to start
with the run yeah gonna push and vice
versa
I'd like David Johnson I think he's got
some potential in this offense but I
don't know enough about how is the
offensive line upgraded at all because
it was bad last year and David Johnson
was bad last year in statistical
perspective new offensive scheme yes but
is that scheme going to have success
week one when you didn't do much of it
at all during the preseason all right so
what we're saying right now is that the
picks I initially said we're in D plus
six and a half at LA Carolina plus two
and a half hosting the Rams Baltimore
minus six and a half at Miami Buffalo
plus three at the Jets Detroit minus
three at Arizona you give me a thumbs up
on Indy a thumbs up on Carolina you said
I understand Baltimore I don't like it
thumbs up on Buffalo plus three
questioning Detroit minus three the
other three games I'm not gonna go into
detail though that were all my fringe
that I was going up and back with
Detroit and Baltimore I need your help
here
New Orleans minus seven which is just
too much I don't I don't [ __ ] like it
Cleveland minus five but I know that the
Sharps are just pounding against
Cleveland so I get it but like I really
don't like Tennessee at all and Tampa
Bay and a pick'em against the Niners
that I look at Tampa Bay with the
weather there the Niners defense
especially their secondaries banged up
right now I think Tampa Bay's offense
it's going to be a shootout and I'm just
taking the home team did you like any of
those more than the
I already said I definitely didn't like
one of them but liking them anymore no I
was saying no then I think I'm gonna
keep those five now if there's any
injuries before Saturday I hold the
right to refuse look you got money on
the line here you have two yes it's the
best information and submit your final
card so if it changes the game or two
here there it's to be expected
all right let's make our first phone
call to our proxy to enter our first
round into the super contest you might
know our proxy so a proxy for everybody
out there is somebody that lives in
Vegas and there are some casinos where
you have to actually have someone in
person to enter your picks for the
contest for the contest yeah not not not
real bets cuz you can't do that yeah now
real just the content yeah all right so
let's give them a call guys how you
feeling if you think I'm doing well I
think you're doing great
you're more dialed in than I expected
Oh bro hello who's this hey who's this
hey crack' what's up bro let's go and
Warren show everyone out here in Vegas
oh man Warren say hi to crack what's up
my man I talked to this guy like
probably like five times yesterday on
the phone we're getting ready for the
season so I have my five picks that I
don't want you to enter them just yet
because I want to make sure that there's
no injury updates before Saturday but
yeah I have I have three thumbs up 1/2
thumbs up from Warren and a I wouldn't
make that bet but I understand why
you're doing it so I'm gonna read them
to you and I want to get your initial
reactions okay sure okay first pick Indy
plus six and a half okay let's go to the
car I'm doing a strange thing this week
I'm not I'm going by really line the
lines where they came when I started or
where they are now let's see Indy plus
six and a half verse the Chargers yeah
okay good I got nothing to say on either
side of that one okay Carol and I saw
Carolina plus two and a half
okay you guys me Millie okay Carolina
versus the Rams
people love that the Rams were basically
a Super Bowl contender they were
innocent both course so first week
coming out and I'll tell you why we're a
little hot on Caroline I know Lauren
kind of liked that team to a little bit
so yeah that's a great great selection
public maybe eat all over the Rams there
so that all right so I'm with the public
on this one crack Baltimore minus six
and a half
you know if I had to pick a team right
now that I'm going to be using in most
of my contests picks believe it or not
I'm gonna be a square and go with
Baltimore Miami is that bad this is more
of a set against Miami than it is awful
okay I think this should be a t-shirt
sometimes it's okay to be square
sometimes it's okay yes okay I'm with
you there next one
Buffalo plus three great line two and a
half most spots most of the sharper
spots in the world that's two and a half
nice I have no problem with that Buffalo
plus three offense Wow
alright and the one that I'm betting
against the the rookie quarterback in
the rookie coach I'm going to troit
minus three probably the least most
interested contest yes of the week and
it's going to be that contest so yeah I
bet you know I wouldn't be picking that
side and I wouldn't be picking the other
side either so okay and the three points
bothers me because there's a lot of two
and a half out there
but hey Arizona could be that bad okay
alright so crack those are tentatively
gonna be my five do you have any that
you'd like to spotlight that I didn't
talk about you don't need to give me
your super contest
I just you know you are my proxy so I'm
asking for guidance Lauren Lauren is my
guardian angel and you're like my
guardian angel uncle where you're kind
of like hey [ __ ] you
so what do you want to do Baltimore I i
I'm using myself so I agree
that I have no problem with your first
three I'm staying away from the Buffalo
Jets and Detroit Arizona Arizona plus
three I actually looked at but you know
the one is this line over the pickup
when they came out month ago it's been
all Detroit money and I sure understand
it I don't have a problem with any of
them I'm not going to use Arizona but I
thought about using Arizona because of
the line yes a little line here the line
was three and it's two and a half I
actually like your picks I look forward
to putting this in and look forward to
doing this weekly I'm sure you're
getting some good input there you
haven't you have any other picks you got
like a crack special I mean look guys if
you wait all my cards Jacksonville plus
three and a half you know I know that
Kansas City is one of the contenders to
go to the Super Bowl this year and I
just think Jacksonville will probably
want to make a little bit of a stand I
talked to warrant a little bit about it
yesterday
yeah their defense is good warrant like
their defense a little bit so I think I
think Jacksonville will be why I'll be
using them on a couple of my that would
be my two picks that I'm going to be
keying with this Jacksonville and
Baltimore that is not the standard
betting these games but this is for
contest pick wise if they're probably
tool that I'm going to be using on most
of my selections I might steal that I'll
let you know guys if you want all the
cracks picks download the crack wheels
app he gives away pick a week and if you
want to pay for more he's got a ton of
picks crack thank you for being my proxy
or the man bro appreciate you guys okay
we can hang up on crack that's the
perfect way I'll call him back later
oh hey guys can you hang up on crack
no I still hear him okay anyway I think
we we went through a lot of the games
how did you feel about episode 1 I hope
that we're gonna make some people money
I think we got some good information out
there and what's interesting is you look
at the four teams that are most likely
to that one that went to the title games
last year yes so that is Patriots the
Rams the Patriots and the Chiefs cheese
right we're
can against almost all those teams Wow
so now you like the Saints so I'm not
saying we're against that one I didn't
say anything on that one but you're
looking against the Chiefs with the Jags
up looking against the Patriots a little
bit maybe you stay in the right number
say no way okay looking against the Rams
for sure with the dancers and then the
Saints you know you could probably sell
me on the Texans Warren I am so excited
to do this every week with you as the
computer models start firing up its
gonna get even crazier we're gonna see
if we can make 1.5 million dollars the
super contest and I of course want to
hear from you guys about what picks you
like why I'm an idiot and how we can
improve this show going forward because
this is just it's a it's an open it's a
wiki we can keep building on it and do
whenever we need to and of course check
out Warren's website sharp football
analysis calm he's gonna be keeping
track of injuries to be honest I'm gonna
go online with my corporate card and I'm
gonna buy a subscription right now
because it's a work expense bang bang
and I need all the information next week
it's good to your theme music from here
on out every Friday love it love it
do you have any final message for the
homies out there the 33 percent good
luck fellas week one can't wait can't
wait on the lef koe min for Ingmar and
Jake and Matt and Nick and everybody in
the back you guys are awesome for Warren
you're the [ __ ] man we will holla
holla holla at you next week peace
[Music]